The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ANA BELL: So I have
this variable name once,
which is umbr-- looks like
people are getting it.
We have a variable called
repeat, which is ella,
and I'm creating a
variable u, which
is the concatenation of that
with the repeat multiplied
by 4.
So I think people are on the
right track, seeing by the 90%
here.
It's going to give me
this result right here.
Great.